humans are funny in that we tend to
learn by experiencing first what we
don't want before we don't want it
rather than saying this is what I choose
and putting our energy in that direction
it doesn't have to be that way we had to
have two Global Wars before we said no
more war we've had to have Holocaust
before we say no more Holocaust and
we've had to have these atrocities
before we say no more rather than
choosing to live and honoring all life
and all beliefs in a universal sense
there is an Awakening of human
consciousness that we've never seen
before and where that leads I think as
we embrace the fact that we are a global
family we may not always like one
another but I believe we truly love them
and I've seen evidence of that you may
not like the habits of one another every
day but when it comes down to life or
death we will lay our lives on the line
for one another that's very unique in a
species so I think Consciousness
definitely there is an evolution in
Consciousness and that evolution is
unfolding it's not being shared in the
mainstream media you're probably not
going to see it on CNN or BBC but we all
know it's there hey it's Evan Karma
Michael and I make these videos because
in my first business I struggled to
believe in myself I quit on my business
partner and the thing that saved me was
watching the successful stories of
entrepreneurs they gave me the
inspiration to keep going as well as the
strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how we can start to shift our
Consciousness enjoy
good
rule number two is be self-conscious
with Bruce Lipton how did you actually
then get results in a relatively short
space of time well the first thing how
does a subconscious learn and that's a
very critical thing uh the conscious
mind can learn from reading a book so
you the subconscious come mine can read
a self-help book and you go wow that
sounds really great and then you find
you read the book but your life is still
the same and it turns out why and the
answer is because the subconscious mind
is more of a habit mind things that you
repeat over and over again so the
reality is if you can stay conscious
be present and when those negative
thoughts come in our head and
psychologists tell us 70 of the time the
thoughts that are going through our head
are negative and redundant so the same
negative thoughts are going through if
you could stop those thoughts if you
could hear them as they come through
like oh that's not going to work or this
will never happen those kind of thoughts
if you can hear them and stop them
consciously say no uh change the belief
right there just give the more positive
thing as you repeat this more frequently
and you keep repeating it the
subconscious mind begins to learn so as
a habit if you stay conscious and you
have to work at it and here's why people
say well how come only five percent from
conscious mind 95 from subconscious
because a conscious mind can think into
the future and think into the past and
solve problems then think about it
yourself most of the time you're
thinking about something well if you're
thinking you're using the conscious mind
well if you're using a conscious mind
for thinking then who's running the show
and the answer is when you're not paying
attention and you're thinking about what
I'm going to do tomorrow your
subconscious is wrong so you used the
words be present be present we hear a
lot so be mindful which really means be
aware yes of what's going on whatsoever
you get an automatic reaction you're
aware of that and you say I don't want
to go there that's an old pattern and
you look at a new way to be in that
situation exactly and you have to repeat
it over and over again because if you
think well I I got mad at myself
yesterday because I repeated that same
stupid thing and I got mad again today
because I repeated the same stupid thing
and then people give up because they get
frustrated and it's like no no it's a
habit so you have to every day but
ultimately you can repeat it yet there
are fortunately now very many new
healing modalities that uh that can help
you rewrite the subconscious beliefs
much faster so I get very excited
because some of this may take work for
people because you have to really be
present and yet we're so bombarded with
information and our lives are so busy
that our conscious mind is almost always
wandering trying to resolve issues and
problems and things we have to work out
which then means the subconscious mind
is running the show yeah and it's very
interesting because most people will be
very familiar with this story I tell it
to my audiences and they all laugh
because they're familiar with it I say
look you have a very close friend you
know your friend's behavior and you
happen to know your friend's parent and
at some point you see that your friend
shares the same behavior as their parent
so you you know you casually volunteer
you go you know Bill you're just like
your dad and that's when you have to
back away from bill because Bill's the
first guy that says how could you
compare me to my dad and everyone laughs
because they're familiar but I say no
there's two very profound points from
that one story and profound Point number
one everybody else can see that bill
behaves like his dad he got his
programming from his dad it's only Bill
who doesn't see it and profound Point
number two we're all built because all
of us got programming and all of us
operate with these programs and we don't
even see we're doing that we even when
told we're doing it will deny that we do
these behaviors because we don't even
see what we're doing that's why it's
called subconscious below conscious
because you went from and quoting from
your book wanting to be anyone but me
yes to being I think you quite yourself
as the happiest man in the world you
felt so happy oh so you proved that this
can work well I had to because I said
when I first started talking about it it
was from an academic conscious point of
view this is what I learned but my
subconscious programs are still exactly
the same so well I had this wonderful
knowledge my life still wasn't anything
I wanted to to brag about it because it
wasn't and and as you know that old game
well who would you like to be and I
could think of anybody I'd rather be
than me And yet when I started to apply
the new science and rewrite the
subconscious so it supported me rather
than the programs of limitation or
disempowerment that we get from our
parents and our community as children
which almost all of us get when I put in
the new programs all of a sudden I
started to find my goodness my life
completely turned around uh all
wonderful things started happening in my
life I was healthier I haven't been to a
doctor in 20 years I I don't need that I
don't take any of their drugs why
because most of the illness is just from
the stress of not living in Harmony and
when you learn to to get rid of the
limiting programs that we got as
children and put in programs that
support you guess what then all of a
sudden the place turns into heaven uh
and it's interesting to people I tell
people will you create your own life and
then they look around and go I don't
want responsibility for this but I say
well you didn't know you were creating
with these unconscious beliefs and and
yet then I tell people especially people
that have fallen in love and people have
fallen head over heels in love I said go
back to that time when you first fell in
love let me ask you a question were you
healthy and oh yeah I was I was healthy
as anything I said you have energy I
said oh I had so much energy made love
for days in a row without even eating
and I go yeah and I go uh and how was
life for you it was so exciting I
couldn't wait for the next day so I said
in this little period that you you know
that I refer to as a honeymoon I say
wasn't life like heaven on Earth and
they go well yeah and I go you know that
was not an accident that was an actual
creation and you say but what was
different that made life uh uh so heaven
on Earth during love and the answer is
because you become very self-conscious
of yourself you don't rely on the habits
the day before you meet this person
you're going to go on a date I say
especially the women I say how long did
it take to get dressed and they say well
it was 15 minutes and I was out of the
house and then I say now tonight you're
going to go on a date with this person
who has just rocked your world and I
said how long does it take you to get
dressed it's like my God it may take an
hour or two and I said yesterday 15
minutes today an hour or two what's the
difference yesterday I got dressed by
habit because I get dressed every day
but tonight I am looking in the mirror
meaning I am self-conscious I am making
sure that I represent myself to be the
fully the best individual I can be and
when both parties are not relying on the
habit and both of them are saying I'm
creating the best I can be they're
living in the moment of them now they're
being very mindful they're being very
present and guess what
heaven on Earth is created rule number
three is develop mindfulness with Jack
Canfield before we get started I'd like
to take a moment to explain why
mindfulness work is so powerful
mindfulness grounds you in the present
moment instead of constantly replaying
events in the past or worrying about
events in the future you are better able
to focus on the here and now and that
allows you to deepen your awareness of
what's happening in the current moment
and how you are reacting to it
you become more aware of your thoughts
and how they are triggering certain
emotions and responses in you and once
you're aware of your thoughts and their
impact on you it becomes easier for you
to choose to think better thoughts and
this is life-changing because your
thoughts are creating your reality so
when you change your thinking you
literally transform the way you
experience the world
and today I'd like to show you how
powerful this can be and how you can get
significant results in as little as five
minutes a day by walking you through a
very simple mindfulness practice that
you can do anywhere and at any time
whatever you want to become more focused
and more grounded in the moment
so let's start by taking a moment to get
settled you can be sitting in a chair or
lying down whichever works as long as
you're comfortable
and now go ahead and close your eyes and
let your body relax into your chair or
whatever you're lying on
and now let's take a minute just to
Breathe In and Out in a natural Rhythm
paying attention to each breath as it
flows in and out of your body
foreign
and now become aware of your body
are you feeling tired
thirsty
hungry
are you feeling any tension or pain in
your body
wherever you become aware of any tension
or tightness just simply bring your
attention to it
and as you breathe in imagine yourself
sending a ray of warm soothing energy to
any area that's feeling tense or painful
and as you exhale imagine the tension or
the pain leaving your body with your
breath
and just keep doing that with your next
few breaths
breathing in soothing warm energy
and breathing out any lingering tension
or pain
foreign
and now begin to become more aware of
your thoughts as they flow through your
mind
and as you continue to breathe in and
out slowly
become aware of the thoughts that bubble
up in your mind
just be aware of the thoughts that are
arising in your consciousness
but don't let yourself get caught up in
them just notice them as they arise and
then let them go
like you're standing on the bank of a
river and just watching each thought
Float by like a boat just drifting
Downstream
and as you think your thoughts remember
you are not your thoughts
you are the person thinking them and now
that you're aware of them you have the
power to change them and think better
thoughts whenever you want
and now take a moment to consider how
you feel right now
and then think about how you want to
feel
as you were becoming aware of your
thoughts you were thinking did you
notice how they made you feel
some thoughts might have made you feel
happy or excited
while other thoughts might have given
you a sudden feeling of anxiety or made
you feel sad regretful or angry
the thoughts you think trigger
physiological responses in you
if you find yourself for living a moment
in your past that you regret you can
experience the same guilt or sadness
that you felt when you actually first
experienced that moment
and if you imagine an uncomfortable
event in the future like flubbing a
presentation at work or an uncomfortable
conversation turning into an argument
you will experience the same physical
and emotional response as you would in
the real experience
your heartbeat's speeding up your throat
closing up feelings of anger
embarrassment or hopelessness
and now begin to think about how you
want to feel right now in this moment
what emotions do you want to be
experiencing right now
and now think about the kind of thoughts
that you would need to be thinking and
the kind of actions you would need to be
taking in order to feel the way you want
to feel
for example if you want to feel happy
take a moment to think about the things
that make you happy
it could be your family your friends
your pet or maybe it's your favorite
vacation spot in the world or a hobby
that you love or your favorite book or
song or band or singer
and when you think about the things that
make you happy you become happier it's
that simple
if you want to feel confident in
yourself think about the things you've
accomplished in your life
and remember that you're still that
person and that you can achieve anything
you can imagine
and if you want to feel motivated think
about the things that motivate you
what is the end goal of your efforts
what will your life look like when you
have achieved that goal how will you
feel
if you want to feel healthy and strong
think about all the activities and other
things you do that increase your sense
of Vitality and help you feel healthy
and strong
think about how good your body feels
when you get regular exercise eat
nutritious food and get enough sleep at
night
and if you want to feel successful think
about the big goals you want to
accomplish in life and if something you
can do today to move one step closer to
those goals
than enough to be a big action but it
does have to be something that moves you
forward in some way
so now just take a moment and experience
the feeling that you want to feel and
focus on what actions you would need to
take today or this week to feel more of
that emotion
so go ahead and enjoy that feeling as
you take a long deep breath in and then
exhale slowly
and now begin to become aware of your
body again
feel your arms your back and your legs
pressing into the chair or onto the
floor
and now wiggle your toes and fingers and
become aware of the room around you by
focusing on any sounds you might be
hearing
and now go ahead and open your eyes and
look around
notice how you feel now compared to
before we did this mindfulness exercise
do you feel a little more relaxed
a little lighter
more grounded
if you feel more clarity around what you
want to be experiencing
okay so now that you've experienced what
it's like to do a short mindfulness
exercise I encourage you to go through
this process at least once a day
an easy way to remember to do this is to
set an alarm on your phone for a certain
time each day
when it goes off do the mindfulness
exercise just take the time to stop and
ground yourself in the present moment
and get clear on how you want to feel
and what you need to do to feel that way
the more focused relaxed and joyful
you'll become also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is be open to
possibilities with Rhonda Byrne what's
the quickest way to hold you back from
the law of attraction
so one of the ways that I talk about the
law of attraction or the secret is is
sort of in a different way from the way
I used to speak about it because I'm
always looking how can I make it even
simpler and and I mean basically that
work talks about the power of the mind
and the power of thought
um to create our physical world and
material world and then The Greatest
Secret takes that to a whole new level
actually and so then you really get to
see that oh my gosh it's super easy to
create anything I want like really so
easy because if we have a belief it's
hard then it's going to be hard you know
and so and so it has everything to do
with our mind and what we believe and so
if we believe a thought it will manifest
end a story so if we believe we are
deserving of great love then we will
manifest it if we believe we're going to
be poor we're going to stay poor
something then it's not going to come to
us and you know it's interesting because
because for all of us you know and
I mean you were very fortunate
thought you had a a childhood where you
were mind was opened and you were opened
and your heart was opened and that's the
biggest biggest thing is to open
yourself to the possibility that
everything isn't the way it appears to
be and so even if you can just open
yourself to that possibility just for a
moment you can pick up it all the next
day you can take it all with you the
next day that it's all real and
everything that you're seeing but if you
just for a moment open to the
possibility that things might not be the
way that you think they are then you
have the greatest opportunity to really
discover something incredible how
incredible you are rule number five is
connect to Greater Consciousness with
Joe dispenza what you're saying is is
that when people have this upgrade they
connect with more of themselves with
essential essentially if we're not we're
not separate from anything then you
connect with more of yourself and you
get bigger your energy gets bigger you
get upgraded makes me wonder like what
is consciousness then because that was
another failing I had was that I was
aware of being waveform and I was I'm
also aware of Being Human so there's
this overlay of Consciousness over the
top of the whole experience ah very good
very good because Source dispure
Consciousness it's the consciousness of
everybody of everyone of everything of
everywhere and everything connected yeah
of course we're fishing water asking for
a drink we're a sponge sitting in the
ocean wondering where's the ocean it's
it's within us and it's all around us
and we just haven't made the time to be
patient enough
to actually put our attention on it and
once we've become aware of it it is
conscious that it's conscious of us it's
it's a collect it's a consciousness of
everybody you're not separate from it so
then there's there's subjective
Consciousness you and I you know there
there is one source but in that Source
there are many but there's one Divine in
that Divine there are many there's one
God in that God there are many okay
everybody's got a spark of the Divine in
them okay so that's subjective
Consciousness and then there's the
objective consciousness
how how come the planets are rotating in
such order how come there's forces of
nature that have
so much order after the Big Bang there
should have been disorder that's what
happens after an explosion yeah and
there's so much order after an explosion
well there's only one reason for that
and that's because there's a
Consciousness that's that's aware of the
whole entire thing because they're very
fabric of everything material is energy
and I mean breaking 99 everything
material is actually energy it's just
stable Consciousness and it's the
slowest form frequency the slowest
energy that's stable that we can
perceive with our senses climb up the
scale closer to source and it gets very
very Dynamic and very different so so
the discovery then
of Consciousness and its never-ending
process of self-discovery and answering
the question is there more because most
people wake up in the morning and the
first thing they do is since the brain
is a record of the past they think about
their problems
those are memories that are wretched in
the brain that are connected to certain
people and objects certain things at
certain times and places the moment you
start remembering your problems you're
thinking in the past that's what a
memory is every one of those problems
has an emotion associated with it the
moment you feel unhappy the moment you
feel discouraged the moment you feel
frustrated now you're in the past
thoughts of the language of the brain
feelings of language of the body so most
people
unconsciously take that thought and that
feeling that memory that emotion that
stimulus and response now the body is
the mind so when it comes time to change
and you got to step from that known
familiar feeling and make a different
choice and step into the unknown the
body says Ah listen
um you think you've been running the
show here for the last 20 years but
actually I've been running the show I've
actually been telling you the choices to
make so you can feel that familiar
feeling to reaffirm you it's an
incredible computer we're just a
simulation so the body begets
conditioned there and now to overcome
the body
takes a will that's greater than the
program to to no longer get up and run
through the same routine that you do
every day and your body wants to in the
middle of meditation saying quit I'm too
tired you got too many texts you got too
many emails you got too many things to
do the body's been programmed to get up
and go and you and you say way way way
wait a second here we're not going
anywhere until I get clear on who I want
to be today and every time you execute
that will that's greater than the
program people say oh I can't meditate
actually you're doing it right actually
that's why it's hard because doing it
you're actually that is the process
right there there's no such thing as a
bad meditation yeah what you're doing is
actually exactly what you need to do and
every time you do that you become
conscious that you go unconscious that's
how you actually develop the skill of
Consciousness it's not being conscious
it's catching yourself when you go
unconscious and people if they can see
the thing is the unconscious essentially
conscious is connecting to everything
which is in the space of nothingness
really but there's a journey to get
there yeah and if you're patient with
yourself and you see that
as a victory
like oh you start getting aroused you
start getting frustrated and you think I
can't do this and you go oh no no no no
no no no we're not going to quit here
that would be me getting up as the same
person I'm curious what's on the other
side of this frustration you settle your
body back down into the present moment
you unfold back into that Eternal space
I'm telling you every time you do that
it's a victory you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and it actually turns out that the
body starts liberating energy it starts
really liberating energy but like an
unbridled stallion it goes oh really you
think that's all you think that's all
you have watch this and then it starts
bringing up memories of the past and all
of that just to feel an emotion and if
you're aware that it's doing that and
you settle it down you're taming the
animal you're teaching it you're you're
teaching it how to change its state
right and guaranteed if you keep doing
that you walk out in your life I
guarantee you'll be less responsive and
reactionary to everyone and everything
so in seven days we see that not only
their dramatic biological changes to
suggest that the person for an
environment
but it it goes for the majority of
people
that immerse themselves in going all in
and what does that mean a different
environment they're in a ballroom
they're on a ballroom I've been to
thousands of ballrooms there's nothing
really exciting in a ballroom what's
exciting in the ballroom they all look
the same and rule number six the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is step out of thoughts with Eckhart
Tolle so thinking
is a wonderful thing
if
you are not
possessed by it
if
you are able to use thinking it's a
beautiful amazing tool for creation
but
if thinking becomes the basis for your
sense of identity
in other words the narrative in your
mind
of Who You Are
the story of me
then
thinking becomes a kind of prison
or to use a different
analogy
thinking
becomes then
almost
like something that possesses you
and you don't even know it
and
when you make the statement I think
I am thinking
it's not quite accurate
it would be more accurate to say
thinking is happening to me
but you can't stop it
that means it must be happening to you
if you don't even want to stop it
must be because
you are almost addicted to it
you think he would die without it
so if you can't stop thinking then
you are not thinking thinking is
happening to you
or you could say you are being thought
you're not thinking
oh by the way
while I speak to you and many of you
know this but it's easy to forget too
since this is a kind of meditation
or not a conventional one
while I'm speaking to you be aware of
the
silent gaps between
sentences between words
be aware or notice them be aware of them
because the meditation part of our
session together here
is in the silent gaps
the rest is just the words
the pointers towards the silent gaps the
pointers towards Stillness
when you become aware of the silent gaps
while I speak
brief like now
and now
while you notice the silent gaps
acknowledge them
you may also notice
that you are not thinking while you
notice
the gaps
and that's meditation
and that way I can talk you into the
meditative state
but you have to be aware that
our session
has two dimensions
the words
and the space
the space is the silent gaps
and not only the silent gaps
it's also an underlying
silence or Stillness would be a better
word
so you notice
those gaps
that's meditation and that from in the
moment of noticing you are not thinking
and as you
practice here
when you go into your daily back into
your daily life
you may notice
silent gaps within yourself
between two thoughts
the space of no thought between two
thoughts
don't need to measure it
in time who knows three seconds
four
so you have now you've then accessed to
a deeper or higher depending how you
want to use the word
dimension of consciousness
oh
my God
and when you notice
the gaps between two thoughts in
yourself in daily life
then they deepen or you become more
aware of them
and they get a little longer
another word for the gaps between
thoughts is a Stillness
to realize that
behind all thoughts
there is a realm of Stillness
and you become aware of it
when
one thought comes to an end and the
other one hasn't started yet suddenly
you can be aware of what is beyond
thought
consciousness
and then you begin to embody that
dimension
in your daily life
and then you become a two-dimensional
being
you're a person
and you are
an expression of consciousness
which transcends the person
it's the consciousness of the universe
of which you are in your
personal self temporary expression
he
you are the universe being conscious
in you
you are the consciousness of the
universe
uh that's a very significant thing
it doesn't matter what you have achieved
or not achieved as a person
more fundamentally
you are the consciousness
of the universe
you are a focal point
of that consciousness
the brain is a computer that's a clear
fact and it has the same functions and
and systems as our silicon conventional
computer that people is watching right
now and so here's the Insight I get a
brand new computer and got out of the
store and I push start and it boots up
what does that mean the screen lights up
I say oh great got a brand new computer
let's do a drawing let's do a story a
spreadsheet and I say no I can't do it I
say why not you got a brand new computer
you say not until I put programs in the
computer can I use that computer
and so I say oh and then after I got the
programs and then I can type and I can
interface the computer but I without a
program I can't do anything the human
brain as a computer gets programmed
starting in the last trimester of
pregnancy through age seven because the
brain function is not high enough for
Consciousness most of the time it's a
little lower and I say that's what we
said Theta hypnosis I say why is it
relevant the answer is very important
how many rules must a child learn to be
a member of a family and a member of a
community there's thousands of rules to
be of you know a person in the community
like a an infant can't read the book I
go no the infant brain is actually like
a video recorder it watches the mother
it watches the Father the siblings it
watches the community downloads their
behavior those are the programs
after age seven a child then can work
the computer and do what it wants okay
so I basically say so it started in
utero this is how uh um a mother can
play music uh through her abdominal wall
you know put the speaker there uh and
repeat that music and guess what when
the baby's born she plays that music the
baby instantly knows that music or the
father talks to the baby through the
abdominal wall uh and repeats this and
when the baby is born the moment the
father says something the baby will know
which one the father is because it
already memorized this stuff it
memorizes what the mother eats ah
because of the nutrition coming through
I say how does all this work simple we
talk about the blood is the culture
medium with the chemistry that
determines the genetics and I go so why
is it real if I say then whose blood is
the fetus using in development I go the
mothers so I guess so why is that
irrelevant well if she's having an
emotional response that's chemistry and
I said she's feeling that emotion
whether it's wonderful love or fear and
I go so why is it relevant that blood
with the same chemistry of the mother is
going into the fetus I go why is that
rub it the fetus feels what the mother
feels if a mother is under stress and
the fetus is getting an experience that
life is very difficult up there if the
mother is feeling love and support and
everything then the life is easy for the
fetus it started learning in the last
trimester
but then for the next seven years it
does the same and I go so why is
irrelevant I go
once I get past age seven my
Consciousness can type on the keyboard
so I can program what I want and then
here comes the monkey wrench and the
monkey wrench is this the conscious mind
which types can think and you go so what
I go thinking is inside
you know if I ask you Jennifer I say uh
tell me what you're doing uh you know on
Tuesday yeah and right away you can tell
me but you'd have to think oh Tuesday
what am I doing on Tuesday I say what's
the point
the conscious mind when thinking stops
looking out at the world and the
conscious mind looks inside so what if
you're driving your car and you're
driving down the street and all of a
sudden you have a thought and I say
conscious mind just not not looking out
anymore I said oh my God I'm gonna crash
the car because of my Consciousness is
inside
that's when the subconscious when the
conscious is thinking the subconscious
is autopilot and takes over like so why
is it relevant I go now science is
recognized 95 of the day is the average
person's amount of thinking okay so why
is it relevant well if a conscious mind
has your wishes and desires and
subconscious as your programs is your
life coming from your wishes and desires
I go up five percent
95 of your life is whatever the hell the
program you got from that seven years is
going to play and if you've got a
program that's not supporting you then
95 of the day your behavior will not
support you because that program doesn't
encourage you okay uh I always give the
audience the same story for 40 years now
okay and you know the story but I'll
tell your community I guess you have a
friend and you know your friend's
behavior and you happen to know your
friend's parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
really want to tell you're afraid to go
hey Bill you're just like your dad I
said back away from bill because I know
what Bill's going to say first thing I
understand how can you compare me to my
dad I'm nothing like my dad in the
audience laughs I go that's the most
profound story in the world right now
I'll tell you why
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like his dad who's the one that doesn't
see it Bill how the hell
that's going to control and while he's
thinking the behavior is playing but
because he's not even looking out at his
own behavior he doesn't even see his own
behavior yes so uh in his mind no I'm
not like my identical but everybody else
can see you behave like your debt you're
the only one that can't see it and I go
so why is it relevant and the answer is
simply this we are all built we all have
beliefs wishes and desires and then we
have to say how come I'm not manifesting
the world I want how come I'm not as
healthy as I want to be how come not
creating the life I want if my mind is a
Creator and I go it is a Creator but
then I tell you which mind are you
operating from
and 95 of the day you're not operating
from conscious wishes and desires 95 a
day the subconscious programs are
automatically playing like what if those
programs are not any good I go
well you won't see it they'll just be
playing you know what you'll see the
result so I very simply I wake up in the
morning with conscious mind today I'm
gonna go find love today I'm gonna get
healthy today I'm gonna get the best job
and then at five o'clock you'll come
home and go oh it didn't happen it
didn't happen and I go then what does
that person think because they're like
Bill they go oh everything's against me
the universe against me
this person is responsible that person's
responsible for not letting me get my
wishes and desires I go no
all day long you were shooting yourself
in the foot with your own behavior and
you didn't even know where the gun was
coming from it was in your own hand and
I say so why is a relevant we have been
programmed to believe that when it
doesn't work we are victims of the
outside when the truth is no 95 percent
of the day we were playing programs that
did not support us and as a result the
end of the day we didn't get that
support but we didn't see it why
subconscious was below conscious was
controlling your life your conscious
mind is I'm going to be healthy I'm
going to fall in love and I go that's
great but that's five percent of the day
yeah but 95 I go I'm coming from a
different program and so when you look
at your life and this is a beautiful
part you can say what are my programs I
just want to help people right away I'll
tell you what your programs are and you
say well how do I know I was being
programmed before I was born I was
programmed from zero to one can you tell
me what program you got when you were
zero no can you tell me program you got
a one no can you tell me the program at
two no about three you might say oh I
remember some things but I say you've
been essentially programmed with no
awareness of the program so you didn't
even see the program and now I say so
what is your program you go
I wasn't there now I give you the answer
and you're ready 95 of your life comes
from the program your life is a printout
of your program look at your life right
now and I'm going to tell you this very
simple the things you like that come
into your life they come in because you
have a program to bring them in yeah the
things you want Health relationship good
job your struggle you're working hard
you're putting a lot of effort in I'm
gonna make it happen I'm sweating I'm
going to work hard
why you're working so hard and the
answer is simply this your own program
doesn't support that you're trying to
override the 95 of the day that that
negative program is playing with five
percent effort going oh I want it to be
successful I go yeah and 95 of the day
you got what did you get from your
parent not smart enough not deserving
not good enough not lovable these are
things that we've downloaded in the
first seven years
and very interesting fact is this for
400 years the Jesuits have told their
followers the absolute truth and nobody
understood what they were talking about
I go what do you mean they would say and
this is a fact for 400 years they would
say give me a child until it is seven
and I will show you the man what the
hell does that mean the answer is just
as I said science has said the first
seven years you're in Theta program
that's where you're learning then I said
but we're about the rest you'll have to
go 95 of the rest of your life program
so if I can control the first seven
years I control the rest and that's what
they said give me a child until seven I
will show you the man meaning if you let
me do the first seven years of
programming I will tell you how that
child's life is going to work out and I
hear this from so many people Gabby I'm
doing it all I'm meditating I'm praying
I'm setting intentions creating vision
boards but I'm not manifesting one
reason you're not manifesting is because
you don't believe in what you're trying
to manifest
when you believe it you'll receive it
but if you don't believe it then you're
just trying pushing control and try to
make something happen that isn't fully
ingrained in your presence in your being
in your energy and so you have to do
your part to get into the belief system
of knowing that this is indeed something
you are worthy of so how do you get into
that grounded belief system create a
vision statement a statement that claims
that your desire is on the way that you
are worthy of what it is that you desire
ground yourself in that statement focus
on it and instead of focusing on the
outcome focus on the feeling of what it
is to believe and know that you are
worthy of your desire if you're wanting
to attract a romantic partner into your
life a vision statement could sound like
I believe I'm worthy of the love that I
desire where I believe that I am ready
to receive that romantic relationship in
the perfect time in order say that
vision statement daily for at least 40
days get yourself grounded in the belief
you have to believe it to receive it the
next reason you're not manifesting
it's because you're trying too hard
I'm sorry to say it but it's true the
more you push the more you control the
more you try the more you affirm the
more you vision board the more the more
the more the less you receive if you're
pushing and you're controlling and
you're trying to make something happen
if you are completely out of alignment
with the universe you're not aligned
with that freedom that presence of Love
The Art of allowing rather than doing
forcing making happen yeah we have to
show up for our life but we can't force
our dreams to become a reality so the
key here is to let go so here's your
message the secret to manifesting is to
forget what you think you need let it go
how do you let it go with this intention
thank you Universe for guiding me to
what is of the highest good for all when
you make it about the highest good and
not about what you think you need then
the universe can truly show up for you
you can relax and allow even more than
you could imagine to enter into your
life
and here's another reason that you're
not manifesting this is going to be
tough for you to hear
because you're not vibrating at the
right frequency
what do you mean well what I mean is
that you're leaning into the negative
you're judging you are focusing on scary
things that make you so anxious and you
just keep focusing on them and dwelling
on them you're obsessed with worrying
you love to overthink things look I
understand that behavior more than
anyone could imagine I'm a recovering
Warrior I'm a recovering anxious person
I've been there I understand that but
when we are not in that vibration that's
relaxed released at ease present
we're actually blocking our
manifestations because that low Vibe
energy is blocking our high Vibe
attracting power so what do you do focus
on the good stuff lean into the positive
look for Solutions rather than problems
stop yourself when you notice that
you're being judgmental or gossipy hang
out with people that make you feel good
do things that make you feel good lean
towards joy and you will be led
when you dwell in that energy of Joy the
universe will deliver so if you're not
attracting what you desire just relax
it's all good focus on these methods
notice when you're out of alignment and
come back to this video practice one of
these methods use these tools ground
yourself back into alignment believe it
to receive it feel good and it will come
to you naturally we have the power
within us to attract what we desire when
we allow our internal condition to
reflect what we want to attract on the
outside so make that your highest prayer
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day
a man took a walk he went for a long
walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt a little
tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I'm well
rested but I'm feeling hungry I wish I
had something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
[Music]
people don't ask questions food came and
he ate
stomach became full
then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared it went drinking people also
don't ask questions so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
your monkeys your tail fell away not me
Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's a
necessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is if
I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they are going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of some yukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization it in
turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is her simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded
cooking people
too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
this things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God is the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want I want to explain something to
you that not many people really
understand I want to talk about the law
of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than Earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work well I use a
diagram to explain the mind now let this
circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body now I want you to
think of this for a moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the Dust
you move into your body and you will
move up and it's how you use your mind
that's going to dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here and that separates the conscious
mind from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed when you're a little baby
this is the way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm now a
paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you were
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for Generations now I'm going
to say that the Paradigm is X-Type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think
and as you think you build ideas there's
a power that's flowing into your
Consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
X-Type thoughts therefore you're going
to be in an X-Type vibration
and that will produce X-Type results now
it's the results you want to change and
to change the results you're going to
have to change what you attract you see
the thoughts that you think control the
vibration that you're in vibration is
nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
body's in and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's a
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the Paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change our thinking but that
doesn't do anything you've got to change
the paradigm and if you don't change the
Paradigm nothing happens now talking
about paradigms is another subject we'll
do that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the Paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a Y
type thought which is totally different
than the X-Type conditioning it isn't
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type done the Paradigm will kick it out
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the Paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration you're in is going to dictate
what you attract
people that are in a poverty
Consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in the results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what I tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but I did
exactly what he said and you know
something my income went from 4 000 to
175 000 in a year and then I took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here I used to
struggle a lot with manifesting just the
idea of it I would watch videos on it
and I didn't understand what they were
saying I didn't I just didn't understand
it was manifesting a lot of attractions
like what are they saying I don't
understand the words that are coming out
of your mouth and I would rewind and
watch the games like I don't get it I
don't understand I don't I don't
understand and it seemed weird silly not
good enough for me to just sit on a
couch and think about money coming into
your wallet or whatever it was that
you're trying to manifest you got to go
do something that in law of attraction
you know action is at the end of
Attraction like you got to go off and do
the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me
first thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
cuddle of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often why that's your reticular
activating system basically saying I
want to pay attention to those things so
that car was still around right I mean I
I got this car we've got a Porsche and
now I see Porsches more often those
Porsches still existed they were they
were already there I just didn't notice
them before and now I notice them
because I have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with
and as soon as I came up with an idea I
was like oh you can't do that or I had
to have the perfect Plan before I would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
let's say you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust it it's to write it and then
go do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times it has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh seventy thousand people
you know I am I am the author of a
best-selling book uh I am like whatever
your goal is and what I think the point
of that is is yes one to see yourself
accomplishing big things uh two to not
have a be so far away that it lets you
off the hook for taking action but I
think most importantly is for you to
feel what it feels like to be that and
the more you feel like it feels like to
be that the more it actually becomes
true if your goal is to speak on stage
in front of 5 000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and just 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something I
would tell other people you know like oh
yeah yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because because it I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big
but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but look I've got I've got a belly or
I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm I
am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like manifestation law
of attraction was way out there stuff
that that I judged and that I didn't
understand and that didn't make any
sense like just go off and take action
guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
one-on-one interview with Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there when you quiet
down this mechanism now all of a sudden
you start connecting to that field and
when you can stay conscious in those
subconscious Realms when you can
literally regulate and change brain
waves now you're in the operating system